is this true you were invited to his
daughter's wedding I know Dustin I know
the hoffmans for years for many years he
was nice to me way back when I was the
young Billy Madison but so yes I went to
his daughter's wedding and when the best
time was a great wedding with my kids my
wife and my kids went we had it was up
in Lake Tahoe and beautiful wedding and
and I wanted my kids to go in the lake
after Lake Tahoe was gorgeous so I said
let's go in the lake and my kids are
freaking out my kids can't handle
anything with water they get a little
nutty and that scared what's gonna
happen and so we're in the little lake
and I stood I started hearing there a
shark in here and I was then it's a lake
it's a lake you'll be fine I like is it
poison ivy you know awake and then I
know your kids they don't walk this way
[Laughter]
kids yeah
anyways I like a lot of times in my life
I have to lie to them and they were like
are there any but there's fish in here
and then I swear to them there's no fish
in Lake Tahoe it's not big enough fish
need bigger space there's a guy fishing
I don't know he's gay he's trying to
find we're afraid of it
[Laughter]
you